another stark reminder this morning of
the scale of the cost of living crisis
the governor of the bank of england
warned of an apocalyptic global food
shortage prices are rising at their
fastest rate for four decades as
financial pressures build across the
country political pressure is building
here on the government to do something
about it the prime minister says he's
focused on the long term growing the
economy and creating better paid jobs
but opposition parties say he needs to
act now
so here are some of the short-term
solutions being talked about in
westminster
a windfall tax is a one-off cash grab
from the big energy firms whose profits
have soared as global prices have risen
labour and the liberal democrats say it
would raise billions and that could be
used to help struggling families and it
wouldn't be the first time labour did it
back in 1997 and the conservatives did
it back in the early 80s raising
billions by hiking taxes on north sea
oil and the banks the prime minister has
resisted so far he says he wants to see
those big profits reinvested to bring
bills down in the future the
chancellor's though seems a little more
open to the idea energy companies who
have made extraordinary profits at a
time of acutely elevated prices
investing those profits back into
british jobs growth and energy security
if that doesn't happen soon and at
significant scale then no option is off
the table
[Music]
the 6th of april national insurance rose
to 13.25
that means that for someone on a salary
of 27 000 pounds they will have to pay
an extra 200 pounds a year critics say
it hits working people at the worst
possible moment and it should be
reversed the prime minister says he
needs the money to help the nhs and the
social care sector recover from covid
except that this breaks a manifesto
commitment which is not something
which is not something i do likely but a
global pandemic was in no one's
manifesto mr speaker
there is an income tax cut coming but it
won't kick in until 2024. some
conservative mps would like to see it
happen sooner but the chancellor has
said it would be irresponsible to do it
any earlier than that however some
economists don't want to see it happen
at all
universal credit was boosted by 20
pounds a week during the pandemic but
that was scrapped at the end of last
year now there are calls to reinstate it
however rishi sunak says he's been
prevented from raising benefits by the
outdated i.t system at the department
for work and pensions which won't let
him
[Music]
without much money to spend boris
johnson has been leaning on his cabinet
to come up with cheap solutions to the
cost of living crisis some of the
suggestions include letting motorists
get mot tests every other year rather
than annually loosening child care rules
on the number of staff required per
child to bring down costs and making
people aware of help they are already
entitled to but aren't claiming like
broadband discounts this is a real
crisis affecting people across the
country but it could very quickly turn
into a political crisis here if the
government fails to get a grip